escorté par des avions de chasse de
l'armée italienne
volodireinski arrive à l'aéroport
militaire de champino de Rome c'est la
première fois qu'il met les pieds en
solitalien depuis l'invasion russe son
arrivée dans la capitale se fait sous
haute surveillance
devant le palais romain du cuirinal
l'hymne national de l'Ukraine retentit
pour le début de sa rencontre avec le
président italien
au cours des discussions Sergio matériel
assure être pleinement aux côtés de
l'Ukraine volody mirzelinski remercie
l'Italie pour son soutien il est ensuite
reçu par la chef du gouvernement Georgia
Meloni d'extrême droite sous la Victoria
remet un allié solide de l'Ukraine tel
la paix ne sera atteinte que lorsque
l'agression brutale et injuste de la
Russie cessera
conclut sa visite en Italie par une
audience ou une quarantaine de minutes
avec le Pape François honoré le
président remet au souverain pour 6 un
gilet par balle porté par un soda
ukrainien le dirigeant qualifie sa
visite en Italie d'importantes pour la
victoire de l'Ukraine qui approche
dit-il
l'Ukraine prépare une contrefensive
d'ampleur pour repousser les soldats
russes qui contrôlent majoritairement
backmouth l'armée ukrainienne selon les
autorités avance progressivement au nord
et au sud de la ville vous le dit merci
peut désormais compter sur une aide de
l'Allemagne d'environ 3 milliards
d'euros pour la livraison de chars de
blindés et de systèmes de défense
anti-aérienne le président se rend
d'ailleurs demain à Berlin pour
rencontrer les dirigeants allemands ici
Charlotte Dumoulin Radio-Canada Montréal